[Music]
jacob is calling hi jacob how are you
hey guys how are you doing better than
we deserve what's up
so my fiancee and i are getting married
in may of 2022
and we are going to be paying for the
majority of our wedding ourselves and i
was just wondering whether you would
recommend one person paying for the
wedding uh maybe me and my fiance is
splitting it half and half i know you
probably don't suggest opening a bacon
count for the wedding i was just
wondering what your opinion was on that
i don't mind opening a bank account for
the wedding and both of you and both of
you fund it and both of you have access
to it
this is a a venture that we are doing
together prior to being married and so
we can fund it
um i just wouldn't share all your
finances prior to the wedding meaning i
would share the knowledge of them but
not the transactions
don't act like you're married legally
before you are
get yourself in a pinch but um
so i i
i don't care who pays for the wedding i
don't know that there's a moral
thing here i mean you know if you want
to go old-fashioned uh the bride's
parents pay for it right that's
old-fashioned obviously that's not
what's going down here
so uh why would one of you or the other
bear more of the cost is there a reason
no there's no reason i was just
wondering whether it makes more sense to
take it out of one person specifically
or just to keep it half and half
seems like there's something else
underneath this question
because it i mean if the wedding goes
off then
it doesn't matter yeah it doesn't matter
the following the following afternoon
yeah yeah i was just looking for your
guy's opinion
do both of y'all have the cash to fund
this wedding
yes
okay what do you make
um i make about 42. what does she make
about 35.
okay
uh do both of you have about the same
amount of debt
uh we need a refund
okay
sounds like everything's pretty equal
yeah we're pretty much on the same
territory as far as baby steps go yeah i
mean i guess you know it would like if
you call me up and you said uh i make
30 and my fiance makes 200
um and she wants to pay for more of the
wedding i would go well that
mathematically kind of makes sense
uh but it's not like a moral obligation
or something wrong and john's right as
soon as you come home from the
from the ceremony the honeymoon
it doesn't matter anyway because it's
all combined at that point and
the net the net effect is exactly the
same after the wedding part of me likes
the idea of y'all two going to get a
checking account wherever you're gonna
bank at your
as your joint account and she puts five
grand in you put five grand whatever
you're paying for this wedding and you
all work from there and then that's your
account you close your two separate
accounts when when you're when you're
married part of me likes that and part
of me thinks man weddings are so
stressful
just somebody pay for this thing let's
get it over with sounds like six months
in another but yeah i don't know it'd be
okay if you fund it together and i i'll
go ahead and give you the other piece of
advice and that is weddings are like
anything else they're a project
and you should
do some planning on them
and set some set a budget
set a boundary and say okay we're going
to spend
x
and here's how much of x we're going to
spend on the photographer here's much
how much we're going to spend on the
reception here's how much we're going to
spend on the dress here's how much we're
going to spend on the preacher here's
how much we're going to spend on the
honeymoon
and the total is the amount that we're
going to have in the account not more
not less we're going to have spent the
money and then if you get in there and
you go well the reception is you know
the reception
this th they want to put these flowers
out and the flowers are we can't they're
not in our budget well they're not in
the budget so we don't put them out and
so you know you have to have some
guidelines ahead of time because you're
going to bump up against a no
and if the no is not brought to you by
your plan then it sounds like one of you
is deciding over the other one
what's going on and you go hey
you can't do an 8 000 address we had 800
bucks budgeted for the dress and that's
what i don't like because then it's well
i'm paying for the address then and you
pay for this and then i'll pay and then
now we're talking division right yeah
you got to have you need an overall
budget that you agreed to for the
project that's how you build a house
that's how you do a wedding it's how you
do anything that's project based
is you start with the line item to
budget
and then you know you may have to make a
few adjustments along the way but we've
got an agreed to value system
of what this wedding is going to be we
care more about the reception than we do
about the flowers
so we're going to put this more money on
it you know or we care more about the
flowers than we do about the reception
so we're going to put this money on it
and you decide that up front and then
when you get down in the emotion of
bridezilla or whatever picking stuff out
then it doesn't all blow up on in your
face or it shouldn't if it does you've
got other issues